[Music]
a splendid day to you welcome into the
what podcast which bands this year that
matter a tour around festival life very
quarter lord taco i'm brad uh hi guys
how's everyone doing
hey great you know i uh i don't want to
interrupt but boy look at that good
looking shirt on lord taco today
man i thought you were telling me okay
okay love it
look at taco
you know
the amount of vanity between me and
barry is
it's a little astronomical it's a little
much it is a little much but i'm ha i am
having a good hair day no is that right
good for you i started to call you on uh
thursday because tell me about a good
hair day i was having an amazing hair
day
barry this is okay dad i was gonna call
it literally i thought i need to call
brad you know dad you know normally what
people would do in the 21st century is
take a picture of it and then text it to
someone
calling them is not going to do anything
yeah but then i don't get the
satisfaction okay
i want the reaction
i need the live
uh-huh you know
you could just facetime me if you want
to facetime me your hair
that's not the same as calling no one is
a visual element the other is audio
all right next time i'll know when i'm
having that kind of a hair day i still
have that boris johnson thing going on
right here
we're gonna get that fixed
this is turned into queer eye for the
straight guy man
hair care product show
taco how's your cut doing
uh
it's it's gonna need some work okay good
it's a little messy from camper this
weekend yeah why were you camping why in
the world would you camp in 25 degree
weather what are you doing why not it's
beautiful they have
waterfall and and trees and it was great
you know they don't have heat
yeah i brought my own we made a fire i
brought a propane heater
we but with a fire though with a fire
how can you ever breathe the next day i
i never can breathe well the next day
um why because all the smoke yeah
yeah well they say smoke follows beauty
so
yeah maybe that's i did once
so you were camping in the in the bus
that's right nice good for you
wow that's not really camping though is
it it's just parking
you literally just drive up and park
what how else am i camping okay
i'm still in a tent
yeah i think
you're not in a tent you're in a car
yeah
it's on top of the bus
the tent's on top
i i guess
you know i again it's it's part of the
world where i just i can't i can't do it
i mean you camp outside of bonnaroo and
that is very strange to me
the only camping brad and me
is bonnaroo
right yeah the only time you leave your
house is bonnaroo barry you came to the
mini room
that's true i had a good time and
you didn't leave or did you sleep in the
car he slept in the car
technically i slept in my driver's seat
in my truck and you didn't came up i was
gone you did not camp
you didn't take his seat belt off
that's true
that is the ultimate bad move i gotta be
safe
hit her ticket
he drove in
rolled down the window said hi passed
out
that's well no i didn't i did more than
say hi i remember because i i rolled in
there with you and mitchell
that's right until five in the morning
that was a long night that was just
sitting in the car
you know
you're like brian stone at bonnaroo just
sitting there listening to the shins in
his car
no i tell you what
that was a bad decision driving home
because i woke up and thought i'm going
home
and i was about
an hour down the road and i thought i'm
i'm still at the party this was not a
good decision well the party was in your
car so it just continued down the road
yeah i hope i might get home
um actually i was going to start this so
it's a quick show today because um uh
i've got a couple things i want to bring
up but the main thing is i had this
really interesting conversation with
jack antonoff uh from bleachers and it
was supposed to be an interview for the
radio station but it started as
um just a just a chit chat about
bonnaroo and he waxed poetic about
bonnaroo in a way that i've not really
heard an artist do in one of these just
radio interviews i mean he's got a new
album he's coming to town and that's
what really the focus of the chat was
going to be about but he just started it
on bottle room and half of our
conversation was gone you know so i want
to play that because it was so it was so
interesting but i've got assurances that
he will be coming back to do a long form
chat with us about the super jam and
um some other things one thing in
particular is really interesting about
this
chat that i didn't even know about he
played bonnaroo before he was in fun
so when he went to bonnaroo with fun in
whatever year that was barry 2007
eight i can't remember but that was not
the first time jack antonoff performed
at bonnaroo he'll tell you what band he
was in
during that chat later on this afternoon
i'm excited to hear it i'm excited to
hear that i'm excited to see what he's
gonna do
well we talked about that he brings it
up yeah he thinks that's what he's gonna
be doing
um
i think that i think we talked about it
right that's going to be one of the more
exciting things
about this year
whatever it is he has in mind because
i i think it's going to be uh
pretty epic well it brings up the the
obvious question
is there a super jam that you remember
more than any oh for me it's easy which
yeah the billy island billy idol and
graham uh larry graham
john oates that was that was the best
one there was no question for me that
was was that the the john
the john oates
wait was it daryl hall or john oates i
know i always have to do the same thing
wait i think it's daryl hall that did it
no it's john oates
was it really yeah it's john oates and
i'll be honest with you if if they both
walked into the room i wouldn't know i
know it's daryl hall daryl oates you
know i'm the same but no i'm pretty sure
uh but that was brittany yeah that was
the brittany year that's right that was
the only one i think that's the only one
i have sat through the whole way yeah we
were i mean it was great it was amazing
we were all all of camp nut butter was
there but was there a
was there a theme yeah no but if you
remember we saw billy idol
uh yeah which was
great and basically walked across the
road there and then that started and uh
he came over and joined yeah
that was my favorite and that to me is
the one
that's what i compare them all to that's
what i think they all should be like
that's what i think well explain what it
uh super jams are somebody curates it
they they basically the whoever they
uh put somebody in charge in this case
it was john oates and they say all right
go get whoever you want
uh you know who's gonna be there and
they curate you know a set 90 minutes
and
in this case larry graham
who was
larry graham basically invented the slap
bass that we all know the
the funk um funkadelic um sound
so i mean it was just amazing
all the people that were up there and
then the songs were great
um
it's
it's just what it sounds like it's a
super jam
uh you know whoever's on the farm come
play
but they they plan it ahead of time it's
not just show up
okay it's curated okay so the problem is
is that most of the super jams are not
ever very good
because they're always so messy there's
there's just there's [ __ ] happening all
over the place i just generally don't
enjoy them for some reason i guess
i guess i don't really know why
i know and that
you're not the first to say that
everyone
that that is gone for many years says
that like grizz did one that i thought
was just monumentally boring and they
become year after year they've become
just a walk by for me until
unless it's somebody that i really
really want to see now i will say the
only year that i can probably i don't
know maybe not
where we check in to get our credentials
at bonnaroo there is a um big ballroom
right next door to it and that's where
they practice the super gym right so
it's a little odd to like see the guys
walking in and out of the door and hear
what's happening on the other side you
know
literally hours before they play it you
know what it is
it's become like it's become like a
vanity thing for them
it's become more about them
than the audience
i think
and that one was not that was about
having fun because
what about the suit what about how about
the the bluegrass ones that ed helms
always put together yeah those are
always great if you like bluegrass then
i don't so but i mean those were always
uh
right i mean those were always well
received yeah people usually like them a
lot and it's surprising it's ed helms
he's so so good right right i'm trying
to think of who else
put together a really good super jam in
the past
the wasn't it uh
john paul jones
from led zeppelin
and um stuart copeland from the police
that was the one i heard that was i mean
that's way back i know way way back and
i missed that one uh because i didn't
you know i didn't know what they were
going to be but there was there was that
was the only other one i ever heard of
that was so epic well there was one that
jack antonoff was with before and it was
that dance party one where they had like
reggie watts came out and did something
um
chance was out the chance is there every
year by the way i mean most years you go
back in the super jam history and chance
a rapper as part of you know a super jam
at least because he's the mayor of
bonnaroo you had run dmc was there
pretty lights did it um and it was just
a big dance party and it did dance song
after dance song but other than that i
can't really remember
i'm the gym genius
when i was costello was there there was
i think that's the same that was the
billy idol year
no no that was no that was that way
all right elvis because kelly my wife
came up for that one that was the uh
springsteen year
uh oh that's right eight or nine
um
but no that's
it's an interesting question it sounds
like the year how about the year where
where jim james was doing it and r kelly
came out and sang sam cook
see that's what i mean a sentence i was
not expecting to say in 2022. you
remember when r kelly sang sam cook at
bonnaroo um it really takes a different
you know
i totally forgot about that by the way
i'm i know i know what i'm gonna hear
but that r kelly show is actually pretty
damn good
he released the doves
the white
it was really really well done and he
was keeping the songs it was hit after
hit but he was keeping those songs at
about a minute 45 a piece and just
barreling through all of those hits it
was uh it was kind of pretty fun to be
honest with you yeah
uh i'm
i'm excited to hear your interview i'm
excited to hear what he's gonna do i
hope we get him later um yeah we we will
and it's going to be a lot of fun and
the the back to the super chat the only
other one that i can remember is the
skrillex one and if you gave me a
thousand dollars i couldn't put one
person in that super jam i don't know
the first person that was in it
that's what i'm saying it yeah it went
from the that billy the john oates one
to man this was
maybe one of my favorite shows you know
top 10 anyway
to be
super jam
well
he explains what his mission is and it's
i mean it's not hard to figure out but
um he at least says it outright uh what
his theme is for
super jam 2022 the other thing i wanted
to get to before i get to the spotify
stuff rolling stone bought a festival
the the magazine rolling stone now
becoming the second publication to get
into the music festival business you
know pitchfork has the pitchfork music
festival and now rolling stone has their
own and they bought life is beautiful
um
you know
any entity that's running one of these
that's not the you know the two
conglomerates i feel is a is a is a
welcomed addition to the to the club but
uh how about that rolling stone uh
entering into the uh music festival
world barry i
i got time to be pressed next yeah we're
next yeah when are we buying a festival
brought to you by
yeah if we did have our own music
festival let's be honest our only
headliners would be repeat repeat repeat
i already know what the the uh corporate
sponsor is yeah we got pbr we got pbr
that people do they like it or not
whether they pay that's money or not
they're going to be that's all you're
drinking
i mean if we did a music festival with
our if we did our own music festival it
would be like repeat repeat cautious
clay
um duran jones and we've got a pretty
good music festival with the the guests
that have been on the show we could
we're going to get a pretty good lineup
here warren treaty uh yophilian i mean
devin yeah i think krungbin till vanessa
yeah yeah bristol we could put together
a pretty good lineup
i
would try to think about the other
artists that we've had on the show and i
can't think of any of them well you uh
you know can't think of another you're
you're you're
guy from uh saint paul
st paul oh yeah we gotta have e.o.b
radiohead be
would that count as radiohead or i'd
just give you guys paul jan away yeah we
could i think we could put together a
pretty good lineup that's not bad i mean
somebody create that poster for us take
all the guests that we have and turn it
into a festival poster i mean i'm too
lazy to do it but if you do it
it would be very exciting for us
i think you got a challenge there taco
you're the you're the graphic guy put
together a list of uh guests that we've
had on the
like
show
a poster
yeah yeah i like it yeah okay
um so let's wrap up with uh our chat
with
uh my chat with
uh jack antonoff who will be your
uh special um
super jam headliner uh doing 1984 jack
antonos 1984 and he'll explain what that
means uh here on the what podcast
i uh i'm so happy to see you again um
mainly because i mean look you're the
most interesting man in music
um
you're very sweet to me and very mean to
you
that's how it's done
i will say though
you know the last time
i saw you specifically it was with fun
um not only in the tour with in the
ryman but also uh early that year at
bonnaroo
i wonder if like you're standing at the
bonnaroo stage was the number one single
years and years and years ago and you
said to yourself i'm going to be my
generations rick rubin
i uh
it's interesting to bring up bonnaroo
and the concept of
you know feeling
excited or proud because bonnie plays a
crazy role in my history because my
first band steel train
through like a weird
uh
[Music]
series of events we got to play the
thursday night one in the morning bonus
slot and this is
four or five okay
historian at my core and i did not know
that yes and and if you what you and as
a boundary restoring you know that back
then that slot and this was before like
even there was like festival apps and
you could curate your experience this
was more back in the day where if you
got on bond room you were gonna play to
fifteen thousand people didn't matter
who you were no one knew my band the day
before we played in atlanta to ten
people they after we played sticky
fingers and little rock for five people
get up as agent vanru
my first experience playing to
a crowd that big and it's significant
because
uh because you can't describe it you
know when you play to 50 people it's a
club show 100 people cool a few hundred
people starts to get this like kinetic
bigger vibe
but i can't tell you what it was like as
a performer to
go from the biggest shows i ever played
with a few hundred people to getting up
at the
probably the the what is the who what
where when what does this tent or that
tend to this
no is that ten and there's 15 000 people
there and i [ __ ]
lost my mind it is still one of the most
formative experiences did you have the
same feeling when fun because the the
crazy thing about the fun show and i'll
say this to anybody to listen and i
don't think it's happened since but
nobody had had a number one single at
the time they played at bonnaroo until
you realize yeah
i didn't know that that was that one was
a little bit less enjoyable because life
was such a whirlwind then um
but then we get i got to do it with
bleachers i think in
2016 or 17 which was one of my favorite
shows and to come back this year and and
do it again and then
do the super jam it's all um yeah like
if you give a [ __ ] about bonder you know
how important super jam is well i mean
look i i
i do i mean bonnaroo is my life i i used
to be in chattanooga tennessee and i
even run a bonnaroo podcast we do a
podcast for bonnaroo yeah on the
consequence podcast network so
um look it's a daily conversation for us
bonnaroo is in our blood and we we live
it and
not only do we live the actual
experience and the life that the
lifestyle that it
really means but the nerdy part of it
right so what i want is how did that ban
that you had first get on that bill in
2004 it was like some really weird thing
with our distributor which was sanctuary
at the time it was a really random thing
i remember when we got
the official offer which like screaming
and celebrating
um i did it three times with that band
over the years once with fun
once with bleachers and then 2022 will
be
the sixth time the second time with
bleachers and then seventh if you go to
the super jam
um
i mean it's sort of like it's it's sort
of the the original
great modern american festival that
actually modeled itself after the great
european vessels hotel doesn't really
count because that's become a whole
different thing
um and then all the other festivals are
well fluid which is great gumball
they're city festivals different things
kind of like that last one first one and
last one where people uh
are just really pop committed for the
weekend
because they're just they're just
they're gross you know they're like not
showering and stuff and i think it's a
different vibe when someone is intense
they're they're like a vibe more feral
than if they're in like a
you know
boutique hotel around the corner that's
right and jack that's what we say over
and over the reason that bonnaroo is so
great and the reason why there's a real
feeling there is because
they're in it the people that go are so
in the the moment and it almost feels
and you can correct me if i'm wrong but
of all the people that we've talked to
they all say the same thing
they can feel it on stage so that the
artist gives it back to them even more
so because of the feeling they're
getting from from the audience
well it goes two ways because it's like
obviously like
i'm not sleeping in a tent anymore but
like you know it's not like
some festival where i'm going to
you know i'm in the mud too i'm in
murfreesboro tennessee like the barrier
entry is so high
um and you feel this way like you know
you go play a show it's like cool
amazing whatever you go play a show in
some random weird place like i remember
we did this like
really weird mountain town in
in colorado once and i was like i think
we're going to come to this
and the people that were there was just
like this shared experience
and uh that's right yeah and then also
this year man like having it canceled
two years in a row once because of the
pandemic once because of flooding that's
right yeah which is
this insult to injury i just think it's
gonna be which none of us saw coming and
then it ended up being such a bigger
event for like the northeast than it was
even for for us in the south let me ask
you when it comes to the super jam what
in the world are you putting together
when you say 1984 are you doing hits
from 1984 yeah i was born in 1984 i
figured that yeah it's also just one of
my favorite years of music i think it's
like one of these like
crazy weird years in music where like
there was this insane cross-section of
uh
of of of things happening that were of
all different genres but all hitting the
world at the same time
um
i like the orwell-ness of it
and so yeah we're gonna play a ton of
music from that time we have
all these insane special guests and
it'll just be uh
a really special one well you really do
sort of um i feel like in everything you
do have a
thread through history right you know i
know there's there's the common bruce
springsteen thing because of the jersey
but i mean you take your your new track
i hear paul simon through this like
crazy uh
you have such a reverence for the past
um i wonder where that comes from
i just like it i mean i think that
i don't think i don't see like art as
this like uh
you know absurdly evolving thing where
you need to
like access like any sort of crazy
shocking
ideas outside of just
telling your story which is the most
shocking thing
so i don't care
if i listen to paul simon or joni
mitchell or something like that like it
doesn't sound
old to me
um
and when i hear something that came out
yesterday it doesn't sound new to me it
just sounds it just kind of hits me or
doesn't
and i think that
i think it's sort of a dangerous road to
go down to like
you know i mean i'm not like using like
i'm not going like full jack white on it
like only using like certain equipment
that's like from a different era which i
total respect to you know like i use
modern stuff oh
i'll put 808 in a song with postering
guitars i don't care but i just i guess
my point is i don't sit around and think
this is pastice this isn't i just think
if it is exciting and if something is
exciting then i think it's modern and i
think if you get into the conversation
of what is modern like you know once it
was trapped and now it's acoustic stuff
and now it's this now guitars are back
it's just sort of like a losing game
because right by the time you have time
to even think about what sonics are
modern
isn't it like arguably not martin
anymore so it's a little like who gives
a [ __ ] so i just
to me i just kind of look for what's
exciting and all of a sudden and all of
a sudden the moments passed you by you
know yeah it's like that uh you know in
that metallica documentary when they're
having an argument about how guitar
solos
are pastiche but then kirk is saying
well to play into what's pastiche isn't
that technically fascination it's like
you know you kind of realize like you're
at your best as a songwriter and a band
leader if you're just doing the [ __ ]
that feels really exciting
and also
it's kind of inherently flawed for an
artist to worry about
what is there isn't modern because it's
kind of on us to decide well it leads me
into another thing that i've always
thought about you i wonder where you
feel most comfortable are you most
comfortable writing for yourself are you
most most comfortable producing are you
most comfortable you know where's the
sound space for you i was gonna say in
the shower but then i realized you're
asking a bigger question
um just i really like to sit there and
think
uh-huh um i do all my best thinking in
the shower it really is my favorite
place in the world but now that i
understand the questions
both
they're
they're different i need both i mean i
think there's a uh
when i'm producing records is i'm tapped
into a little bit more like a craft
space
which is um
an exciting space
uh when i'm writing it's a little uh
lonelier and scarier
because it's so vulnerable
yeah and i gotta wrestle with it myself
and
you know i'm not writing lyrics for
anyone else and you know i could write
tons of music and produce things but
as soon as you start
you know just kind of writing your poems
and putting them into the songs it's
just a different thing
it's funny because the two process the
two producing records making my own
records they're
so inherently similar and different at
the same time like my body does the same
thing
and in the same place i'm doing the same
things but it all feels uh
very different i've never thought of the
right analogy but but one day i will
well i wonder you know when you are
doing your own thing of course there's a
level of vulnerability there that has to
exist
when did you feel as though that you
were comfortable with your vulnerability
is there a certain age was there a
certain song was there a certain moment
you're like okay i can manage this
because it's a frightening place to be
i felt comfortable with it um but it
took me years to feel control sharing it
so it was never anything that upset me
or embarrassed me or made me feel
uncomfortable it actually made me feel
sort of vital and alive
when i would do it um
but then it took me some time to
[Music]
have enough armor to say yeah and i'm
gonna throw this out there
and does that lend you to being a better
producer because you can talk to to
artists and say this is how you can get
there or do you inherently work with
artists that are already tapped into
that sort of vulnerability
well i don't think i don't i don't think
it's a process that you ever let go of
like i think you're always re-tapping
into it reminding yourself how to get
there
playing to your strengths making sure
that like bad voices aren't guiding you
and i definitely think it makes me
better at all my work because
it's about understanding you know i
i'm not saying this in a critical way
but you're a songwriter you're not you
know if you're someone who can put a
couple chords together in a room with
someone you're honestly a songwriter you
know i'm talking about people who sit
down
and write music and lyrics together
about that that came from nowhere if you
if that's something that you do and need
to do then you can see it in other
people um and you can see the glory in
it you can see the
um anxiety in it so uh i have a lot of
sympathy for it
and so i think that uh has always helped
me relate to you know
people i'm working with well i mean you
tap into something i wasn't going to get
into but the taylor damon auburn thing
um
you know you're their songwriter or not
i mean that's a really great way of
putting it his version of being a
songwriter is very very literal
well well it's literally he's also wrong
but i think the damon thing what it says
to me
because obviously it's completely absurd
and everyone knows that um you know
you're talking about one of the greatest
songwriters
relation who has her
name as the only name on many songs you
know like that's
you know you don't need me to explain it
it's fact
the problem i had with the damon thing
beyond
beyond what he actually said is
i don't like it when artists
who are who are the concept of being an
artist to be very tapped into a deep
place i don't mind talking [ __ ] this or
that whatever but i don't like it when
artists sort of like almost take this
trumpian approach of just making things
up like
i don't care if damon albarn or anyone
likes or doesn't like something but to
unequivocally make a statement that
isn't true that you actually have no
idea about
and not to get too deep on it but isn't
that kind of everything that's wrong
with our world at the moment there's
just people talking about [ __ ] that they
have no clue about
um
and but the president controls gas
prices
i i mean but but you know what
i expect it from politicians i expect it
from
idiots and herbs and
corporate [ __ ] and whatnot
i like the term herbs yeah i use a lot
when it's from someone who's in a band
and is an artist i'm like i don't know
man like
you know it's just a vulnerable thing to
be an artist and a songwriter yeah um
you want to you want to go full liam
gallagher and be like this person sucks
separate whatever you know do you but to
just sort of like launch
this like
weird baseless
concept with this bravado that such fact
i mean i tweeted this but maybe um
before you say that you should uh shut
the [ __ ] up
well i look i i could literally talk to
you all day i find you to be the most
interesting person in music i um
i i think the new album is terrific i
can't wait for you to come to new
orleans um i don't know when the last
time you were in new orleans was but
the last time you played there was jazz
fest before that voodoo and we've never
headlined the show there so
uh
it's there's a lot of firsts on this
store well we've got a lot of firsts to
take you around town and you get to town
i'm going to wrap it up with one thing
and it's not to the taylor point but i i
do have one odd question
what is the oddest person because you've
worked with so many people and so many
weird people reach out to you what's the
oddest person to reach out to you um
the oddest person to reach out to the
one that you never expected in a million
years
um
they didn't they didn't personally reach
out but i got a call once about barbra
streisand and i was like whoa
so that's that's the answer there i mean
that that makes that makes uh that makes
my jewish grandmother very excited yeah
very excited made mine very exciting
jack i i like you so much and i can't
wait to see you in new orleans i'll see
you at bonnaroo and um you know we'll
travel the farm can't wait i'm happy i'm
happy to talk with someone who
understands the
level of power
let's let's do it again let's talk
andrew just talk shop
again yet see you take care brad yeah
[Music]
[Music]
consequence podcast network